it's spooky season so here are some of  the coolest Halloween themed airbnbs  that you can rent did you know that you  can rent the entire scream house what  better way to watch the newest Scream  movie than in the house where it takes  place bookings open October 12th  now this one will fulfill all your  childhood dreams you can stay at the  Hocus Pocus Cottage  chanting now this is an exclusive stay  that's first come first serve for one  night only on October 20th and last but  not least you can stay in the Swan House  from Twilight and recreate all your  favorite Twilight moments  now fun fact Saint Helens is also the  town that Halloweentown is based off of  so Bella Swan technically lived in  Halloweentown but they decorate the town  every year for Halloween so you get two  movies in one  [Music]